(logo whooshes)
- Hey, guys!
First of all, thank you for clicking.
You're about to watch a new video
or another video on YouTube.
And before you do, 212-931-5731.
If you are getting value
out of my YouTube videos,
what I'm doing in my text
community is bonkers.
It's instant, it's access, it's exclusive,
and just been a lot of fun,
and I've just enjoyed
texting back and forth
with a lot of you.
212-931-5731.
I'm sure they're editing something.
Team, I know how you do it.
Please join my texting community.
And now, enjoy this YouTube video.
You could always go back
and do the shit how to do!
I'm so confused by this.
But I don't want it to not work!
No shit!
(audience laughs)
I'm aware that you don't want
it to not work, it just might!
And as long have a relationship
with winning and losing, you're good.
This is about having a
relationship with losing.
The amount of insecurity
that's out there is absurd.
People are scared about losing.
To who?
Who the fuck are you scared of losing to?
What's gonna happen, your mom
is gonna call you and be like,
you're a fucking loser,
I told you you should've been a nurse?
You can say, fuck you, mom!
(people laughing)
- [Both] Hey!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(electronic music)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(smooth techno hiphop music)
- [Man] I make a lot of content
and I try to do my best to kind of--
- Who's buying your product?
- [Man] Primarily an
end user, a salesperson,
or a small organization right now,
maybe, 10 sales per million.
- LinkedIn, bro.
You need to make 25
pieces of content a day
for LinkedIn specific.
When people think of
salespeople as one thing
versus a saleswoman who
happens to be a Falcons fan,
that's a whole different.
My game is in perpetuity.
People like salespeople,
and I'm like, no, no, no.
They're like, "How do I make
a hundred pieces of content?"
I'm like, okay.
Well, first of all, there's 50 states.
So there's 50.
Hey, Alabama!
Hey, salespeople in
Alabama, it's your boy.
That's already 50.
'Cause I can promise you
when you run ads against small businesses
or sales organizations in Alabama
and it starts with, what's up, Alabama,
that already does better than it says,
what's up, it's your boy, Gary.
I know it's true.
You start then saying,
you said then do that piece of content
when the Auburn Alabama game is going on
and you make some sort of
reference point that says,
if you're an Auburn fan, leave a comment,
or if you're a 'Bama fan
leave a comment in LinkedIn.
Whoever wins the game,
that person gets 10% off,
the other one gets to cry twice.
(audience laughing)
And so if you look at the
collective reaction to that idea,
that's why I win,
'cause I'm in the game of ideas
and then just making shit.
LinkedIn is uncomfortably under priced.
Organic, let alone paid.
You need to go (clicks tongue).
If you make no content anywhere else,
which is so against my macro thesis,
but if you didn't
and you made 100 pieces
a day for LinkedIn,
that was specific to
psychographic, demographic,
location, age, gender, sex, you will win.
- [Man] Personally.
Okay, that helps out a lot.
- I know it well.
What's really awesome for
me is it's gonna work.
- [Man] Yeah, I believe it.
- Good.
It's kinda believing that if you eat well
and you work out everyday,
you'll look better.
- [Man] Right.
- I know you believe it.
I'm telling you to fucking do it.
- [Man] What would you say
would be second best place?
- Nothing.
- [Man] Just one thing?
(audience laughing)
- What that would be like
if we were kids and
only wanted to eat candy
and I literally walked in right now
with a fucking truck full of candy?
And you'd be like, yo,
where else is there candy?
I'm like, motherfucker, we
can't eat all this candy!
That was the question.
- [Man] So push all my shit on LinkedIn?
- Yup.
- [Man] And just destroy it?
- Yes, but bring them value.
- [Man] Of course.
- Well, that's a challenge too.
That's not so easy.
- [Man] I don't think it's terribly easy,
but I think with enough content,
I can start digging into it.
- Correct, and then
start reading comments.
Ask questions.
One of the things that very few people do
is make content to ask questions.
I love that.
Because then you get
answers in the comments,
which then leads you to
the next piece of content.
So much of my content is actually not made
for any other thing that
an insight to a hypotheses.
It's how I got to all the
content that I talk about today.
There was no strategy session
where I'm like, I'm gonna
make content about parenting.
That was a thing that happened
out of making all the content
that made me get to the realization
of so many opportunities
and vulnerabilities.
That's why it resonates.
The reason my content resonates
is it comes from the community.
(smooth electronic music)
You've been enjoying this like crazy, huh?
- Yes, sir.
Hey, man.
- That makes me happy for you.
- It's a nice inside peek of the world.
- That you love so much?
We're in Atlanta in A3.
What is that, A3?
Is that what this is called?
Oh, for the same.
- It's nice to meet you.
- When you think about the importance
of using tech, music, and culture
the reality is is it's like
cooking a perfect meal.
If you're missing an ingredient,
you're limiting the upside.
And the reality is when you
think about those three sectors,
they're the foundation of
where society's attention
and execution is.
So to me, the importance
is like any perfect meal.
You need all the ingredients.
When I think about things like
A3C and other things like it,
the number one thing that comes to mind
is if you're not putting
yourself out there
and going to the things that
are educating, inspiring,
and allowing you to have fuel to execute,
I think you're limiting yourself.
So for me, my last parting shot
is go out and do network, meet, consume,
and then most of all: execute.
(techno music)
Yo, what's good, fam?
It's Gary Vee.
A big shout out to the
Gary Vee Espanol community.
Big shout to this man right
here, fucking brains and looks.
Look at this dude behind this operation.
Just wanna say thank you so much.
Sorry I failed all my Spanish classes.
Otherwise, I would've
dropped something on you,
but I got nothing.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- That is!
We're here, we're here.
Live that life.
You got one of 'em, fucking execute.
- You tell 'em.
- Follow this man, he's doing it.
You can do it, everybody
can fucking do it.
There ain't nothing fucking stopping you
except your fucking dome.
- Yes!
- I'm so sorry.
- Man, if I could rap, I'd be huge.
I'm such a good storyteller.
I can do so much fun shit.
It would be so good.
- [Man] What would be the album cover?
What title?
- Probably like a little
boy on a lemonade stand.
(everyone laughs)
(rock music)
- [Announcer] Gary Vee!
(audience cheers)
- Yo!
Yo, what up?
What's good?
What is good?
Damn.
Climbing this shit.
All right, got that.
What's good, Atlanta?
(crowd cheers)
What's up?
I love when the haters
come out at me and be like,
don't listen to this fool.
He got fucking shit given to him.
Motherfucker, I got nothing given to me.
I got the right to work 18 hours a day,
365 days a year for my dad
and then leave at 34
with no fucking money.
That's the right I got.
But what I knew is the
shit that I spit to you,
which is you're young,
I knew that I wanted to
get back to my parents
'cause I was grateful as fuck
that they took me out of
that shit hole Soviet Union,
I knew that at 34 that I was still young.
I know that I'm fucking young at 43.
I fucking do business with 78-year-olds.
These motherfuckers think
they're living another 100 years!
(audience laughing)
It's mindset, bro.
I don't understand.
I got people that are 20 that are like,
"Oh shit, in two years, my life's over."
And then there's people
that are 82 and like,
"Man, I'm building some shit
"that's gonna launch in 30 years."
And I'm like, "Motherfucker,
you're gonna be dead!
(audience laughing)
"The fuck are you talking about?"
Mindset.
We do not have a good
relationship with time.
We don't.
We're impatient.
We're impatient because we care about
what other people think about us.
That's the fucking game.
You know it, I know it.
We're doing way too much shit
based on other people's fucking opinion
and the only thing that I got lucky with
is when I was 26 and I was
carrying out a case of champagne
for my friends when they
would stop by the liquor store
and they would laugh at me
when they went in the car
'cause I was working for
my dad's liquor store
and I was such a loser,
only thing that went through my mind is,
laugh now, motherfucker,
because I'm not worried
that I'm down 20 points
in the first quarter.
This shit only ends when triple
zero hits the fucking clock.
(audience claps and cheers)
And so I highly recommend,
'cause I got so much love for this room,
for real for real,
that all of you realize
it's not even halftime.
It's not even fucking halftime.
For me, let me make you
one promise this evening.
You find what you're looking for.
You wanna find negativity?
It's easy as fuck.
You wanna find positivity?
It's actually easy as fuck.
My big thing is that I'm trying
to get other people that are happy
and positive and optimistic
to post more of that.
It's the biggest fact.
We are loud as fuck about negativity
and we're quiet as shit about positivity.
And if I leave with anything here,
we need to change that dynamic.
This is why people are so fucking confused
because people are quick
to spit negativity,
but they keep positivity in them,
which is why everyday I
take on the responsibility
to go the other way 'cause it's in me.
I'm grateful.
I'm grateful for the at bat.
I was growing in the Soviet Union.
That place fucking sucked shit.
(audience laughing)
I got lucky to get the
fuck out and I'm grateful.
I don't know if any of
you've seen this video,
but it's one of my
favorite things I put out.
The math behind being alive is crazy.
400 trillion to one, 400 trillion to one!
You are more like to win the lotto
seven times in your life
than to be in this fucking room.
Your mom could've got up
for another glass of wine.
(audience laughing)
You could've been a fucking tree.
(uplifting music)
- So my own question is this.
I own multiple businesses,
but I'm trying to find balance
'cause I'm like, I can
put all of it into one--
- What makes you happy?
Because look, you're talking to somebody
who does 800 things
because my theory is like.
if I've got 800 balls in the air,
and let's actually make it real,
if I've got 44 balls in the air,
I'm okay with seven breaking,
'cause A, I don't give a fuck
about your judgment on those Ls,
and that's the big one.
And two, I still got 37 balls in the air
and that's how I like to juggle.
Other people are type A.
Really, they just enjoy
one thing, head down.
There is no right answer.
The reason I said it's a
bullshit that you need seven,
you don't need seven
different streams of income.
You could.
There's a fuck--
- I have three others though.
- So enjoy it, bro!
Be happy!
As long as you can deal with the judgment
that when you talk shit
that your fucking burger
business was gonna kill it,
but then it was one of
the things that dropped
because you were worried
about something else,
as long as you can deal with those Ls,
then just make yourself happy.
(audience applauds)
That's what I do.
I'm not worried if my wine or my cases,
I'm not worried what fails.
The fuck does that have to
do with you judging my Ls?
This is about having a
relationship with losing.
The amount of insecurity
that's out there is absurd.
People are scared about losing.
To who?
Who the fuck are you scared of losing to?
What's gonna happen?
You're momma's gonna call you and be like,
you're a fucking loser,
I told you you should've been a nurse?
Say, fuck you, mom!
(audience laughing)
I'm on some serious shit right now!
What? Who?
Whose loss is it besides yours?
'Cause I promising you
something right now, my dear,
the number one thing every
fucking person in here
should be worried about is regret.
You want some real poison?
You want some shit that really hurts?
Wait 'til you get to 80
and you regret that
you didn't fucking try.
- [Woman] That's right!
- I know.
You know why?
Because you people should
be spending more time
with elderly that aren't their family.
You speak to elderly
that aren't your family,
you see one theme: regret.
They don't talk about what they did,
they talk about what they didn't do.
So, what?
Go, go hard in Atlanta.
ATL, everything's happening here.
You go hard.
You go at it real hard for a couple years.
Three, four, five,
whatever your patience is
based on finances and what
you want in your life,
and if you decide to go back,
at least when you're 92,
you're sitting there and
being like, man, I wish.
You don't get I wish out of your mouth.
- [Man] Exactly.
- Atlanta, thank you so much!
(audience applauds and cheers)
Thank you so much!
Fucking love you!
Do you!
Let's go.
- Great content!
I'm gonna your name tattooed on my back.
(people chattering)
- Fucking audience!
- Hey, hey.
- People, people!
- Stand down!
- What's good?
- Gary Vee, represent.
- One life, fucking live it.
- Way to come to tell
us about your proverbs.
We appreciate it.
- Happy to, happy to help.
Anybody you want me to talk to next year
that you try to recruit,
I'll get on the phone and
be like, do this event.
- For sure?
- I mean that.
- [Woman] I'm scared 'cause the military
was always the deal with me
so I'm like, I have to now--
- I don't know enough about the military.
Are you able to go back
in a year or two if you--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, so that's honestly,
that makes me so happy
'cause I wasn't sure.
I was like, oh fuck, I
don't know if they're like,
you have to rely on that.
You have to know that you
know that, it was stability.
You're gonna go chase your dream now,
just like I told that young
lady with the nursing stuff.
You're good, go hard at this.
You're in the right fucking city.
Go hard.
- And it's like
I know that what might
happen is like this, I--
- But you know what?
Don't even think of it that way.
That's more like, damn, if
I have to go back, I lost.
Don't even think about that.
Instead, be like, yo,
that's always there for me.
First of all, you're young as fuck.
You're young as fuck.
That will always be there for you.
And what that then does
is it makes it look like
a nice stable thing if needed,
versus, oh, I fucked up.
First of all, don't demonize something
that you're doing for all of us, for real.
And number two, this
will give you more time
to do your thing.
The biggest mistake that people make
when they come out of
military, out of school,
out of a job they don't like,
out of a bad relationship
is they don't give themselves enough time
to win in new shit.
- I feel like I always
worry about the things,
'cause I graduated from Kennesaw State,
and I always worried about
the financial side of things
versus actually chasing the dream.
- The happiness.
That comes down to spending money.
If you can live more humble,
you can hold your breath longer.
- Okay.
- I just wanna tell everybody,
people are giving up on their dreams
by buying fucking Yeezys.
- [Man] Facts!
Bullshit.
- If you can afford it,
buy a fucking Benzo,
I don't give a fuck, but if you can't,
and it's buying shit that
made you have to go back,
then you fucked up.
If you can afford it, buy anything.
Buy a Lambo, buy an island,
I don't give a fuck,
but if you're buying
shit that then takes you
out of being able to chase
your dream, you're fucking up.
So really be thoughtful about your money,
and do some side hustle shit.
The flipping stuff I talk about,
get a job that fucking sucks,
but it lets you chase your dream longer.
And then you've always
got the last thing there.
But be patient.
It's impatience, I'm telling you.
People are impatient.
- Can I get you to say
Pre-Game Radio Podcast?
- Pre-Game?
- Pre-Game Radio Podcast.
- Yo what up, it's Gary Vee,
Pre-game Radio Podcast motherfucker!
- Yeah!
Oh, thank you!
I love you!
Oh my god!
- Yo, that legit pep talk
shit while you was talking,
I got the most views than I ever got
on any of my Instagram video.
- Listen, I'm here for a reason!
- 30 minutes
while you were talking!
- I'm here for a reason!
- You right.
- To like get it popping for your shit?
- Yeah.
- Pay TikTok influencers.
Bro!
- Not even Instagram
and all that?
- Dude, I'm telling you.
- Yeah, you gave me some ideas.
The LinkedIn and shit.
- I'm telling you, bro.
- Pay TikTok influencers?
- Because they don't know
how much they're worth yet.
- They got a million followers,
they haven't gotten paid yet.
- Damn!
- I'm telling you!
- I appreciate it man, thanks, man.
- My momma's on the phone,
she wants to say hey.
- Hi, baby!
- Oh, Gary Vee!
- How are you?
(woman squealing)
What's good?
Yo, how's that bubblegum?
- [Woman] It's awesome!
(both laughing)
- I love your boy, good job!
(hiphop music)
Fucking phenomenal day.
Long, operational, business
day in Chattanooga,
and then came to the A
and fucking dropped it.
So much love in the room.
This fucking town,
I can't tell you how
much love I have for it.
I can't wait for you to watch this thing
and drop me any single comment
or hit me up on social on what you thought
and text me 212-931-5731.
We love the A.
- We love it so much.
- And the A loves us.
- [Man] Yes, sir.
- It's crazy.
That was good.
- That was awesome.
That was huge.
That was just cool.
That felt good, you know what I mean?
That felt like it was important.
That was meant to happen.
- Talk to you soon.
- That was cool.
- [Man] I will be on your podcast,
is that what you're saying?
- Bet.
You do 50 of your own
podcasts and you're on,
or you hit me up on social
once a week and be like,
yo, I'm the good looking dude
with the hair from the A,
and I'll just pick one
random time to have you on.
- So 50 of my own, that's what we do.
Well, how about this,
how many like do I gotta get on this video
for you to get me on there?
No, you're not doing that either?
He ain't doing the likes,
'cause he knows it's fake.
He knows it's fake!
Gary is woke!
(Gary laughs)
(hiphop music)